could be the moment a new government was
formed heads of eight parties making up
a majority Block in the lower house
signed a memorandum of understanding at
the Forefront the leader had moved
forward their pick for prime minister
the man at the moment swamped for
selfies everywhere he goes but there's
one major obstacle 250
military-appointed Senators who don't
like him nearly as much as his teenage
fans the struckle of politics of elected
versus appointed is being cleared and
there's a new consensus moving forward
and hopefully that we have enough number
that reflects that in any functioning
democracy in the people that comes out
come out with the Mandate from the
people has the right legitimacy to
govern
but Thai politics is a tough business
alliances easily broken and allies
abandoned move forward's main Coalition
partner is per tie if the Senate refuses
to endorse Peter they could form a
different Coalition with parties backed
by the military
that might be hard for their supporters
but would give them easy access to the
reins of power in the beginning they are
forming together with move forward if
move forward fail should we bring the
country to this whole this
stagnation the third and least likely
option is a minority government led by
the generals who seize power in a
military coup in 2014. that
Administration would almost certainly be
immediately toppled by a vote of
confidence
but with Senate support could keep Thai
politics in a deadlock for at least a
year
the importance of the unelected Senate
hasn't been lost on protesters picketing
outside the Parliament building
they want to make sure the Senators
listen to The People's voice
if they play outside the rules I think
people who are not here will feel very
upset and will be ready to come out on
the streets to protect democracy and
that is a potent threat
and that is a potent threat
this is quite a mild well-behaved
protest but it was just two years ago
that thousands of protesters stormed
these Gates trying to get into
Parliament and there's a real concern
that if the Senators defy the will of
the electorate that kind of social
unrest could return
Tony Chang Al Jazeera Bangkok